[Music]
so let me just get started here
first off Who am I and why I'm on stage
in front of you well my name is piotr
sohbat i'm a senior engineer on the
personalization team at Spotify in New
York City
you can find me on Twitter at Pisa bot
or tweet at Spotify engine but this talk
feel free to take photos and hashtags
and all the things the kids do nowadays
so if you haven't respond to Phi we are
one of the world's largest audio
platforms we've transformed the way that
people access and enjoy music around the
globe
we proudly use Google cloud platform to
power the experiences that we give to
our 200 million monthly active users we
serve more than 40 million tracks to
them across more than 79 active markets
we're also today talking about
specifically one Google cloud technology
which is Google cloud BigTable if you
haven't heard a big table before
BigTable is a high-performance wide
column store you can think of it very
rare roughly as a key value store that's
distributed across multiple machines and
is very very high performance and
parallelizable technically it's a sparse
distributed multi-dimensional sorted map
BigTable is a non relational database
meaning that there's no joins it's not
like a sequel database and it allows for
easy scaling by increasing the number of
nodes in the cluster that's essentially
the only dial that you get to turn with
BigTable is the size of your cluster
it's scalable to petabytes and indeed
we've scaled it to petabytes that
Spotify that uses wide columns and again
it's non-relational so it's not like
your your my sequel or your Postgres
tiles of databases and like I mentioned
we use a lot of Google Cloud BigTable at
Spotify across the company we have
hundreds of BigTable clusters thousands
of BigTable nodes and petabytes of data
stored across all of that all of those
cloud Big Dipper clusters so lots and
lots of juice lots lots of usage of
BigTable across everything that you see
in the Spotify app some good examples of
that are some of these personalized
experiences that my team works on so
personalized via cloud BigTable are
things like the homepage so if you open
up Spotify on your mobile app the very
first thing you see personalized content
for you
well that view is powered both at the
surface level and down underneath by
cloud BigTable we also power things like
discover weekly our weekly playlists of
tracks that you think you are definitely
gonna like this week by BigTable
at the surface layer so serving the
direct tracks to your phone as well as
underneath to power the recommendations
and another example is the recommended
song view so if you scroll to the bottom
of any playlist that you make on Spotify
and and see a list of songs we'd
recommend that you add to that playlist
because of similarity that's also
partially powered by Google Cloud
BigTable so BigTable really kind of
underlies a lot of the features that we
have on Spotify if you're not familiar
with God BigTable itself it allows for
very expressive schema designs so I
mentioned before that it's non
relational and the schema that it gives
to you is something like this you can
have a row key and all of your data is
indexed by this single key so you don't
have multiple indices or different ways
to cut the data you essentially have a
key that you can use for lookups
and then a value that is this kind of
multi-dimensional object here you can
have multiple column families within
that row multiple columns within each of
those column families and multiple
values within each cell as well and
those values are all sorted by timestamp
so you can even do versioning in here
and have some sort of likely exploration
of these values as well and this is all
provided to you by the very expressive
BigTable API and I don't want to get too
much into how BigTable works under the
hood because I'm a Spotify or not a
Googler but BigTable one very important
thing about how it works and how it
stores its data is that the nodes in
your BigTable cluster are compute only
essentially so while you might be able
to increase the number of nodes that
serve your cluster that gives you more
capacity but it doesn't change where the
data is stored the data in your cluster
is stored underlying in the Colossus
storage layer there which is a Google
technology that is not directly exposed
in Google Cloud this means that if you
want more capacity if you want to add
more more requests per second to your
system you can add more nodes and this
simply recharges the data across your
nodes and changes which data each node
is responsible for so this doesn't
actually change what they did it is
stored it just changes which nodes are
responsible for which data and this will
come up later on in the talk about how
we can scale BigTable very effectively
so I'm going to talk quickly about three
different common Cloud BigTable usage
patterns that we've seen in our usage of
BigTable at Spotify we have lots of
different products as I mentioned
earlier and they all use some variants
of these patterns that we've seen the
first pattern that we see is using cloud
BigTable as a real
time data store so using it to serve
some data in real time they might be
computed offline or in batch the second
pattern that we've seen is using cloud
big table as a caching layer which
allows us to well essentially use it as
a large distributed automatic cache and
the third pattern is using it as a
platform datastore which takes a little
bit more explanation so wait until I get
there to talk about that so first off if
we use BigTable as a real-time datastore
BigTable allows us to bridge two
different worlds of data processing we
can do big batch offline data processing
that takes lots of resources lots of
time and lots of different machines and
then dump the results of that data
processing into cloud BigTable to serve
it in real time this allows us to get
very low latency reads and kind of like
write this data all at once and then
read it multiple times when different
clients request this data this loves
BigTable to kind of bridge these two
worlds and do something we couldn't have
done before right you can't do this kind
of thing if you're reading off of Google
Cloud storage or many other kinds of
databases the BigTable really handles
this load very very well the input data
for a lot of our different products for
example let's say discover weekly might
come in in batch we might train a model
or do some sort of recommendation
product in cloud dataflow which is
google's batch data processing framework
and then the results of that that
computation and up getting stored in
BigTable by simply writing a huge amount
of data from dataflow workers into a
BigTable cluster directly and the data
sizes depend on the application here but
typically we tend to use gigabytes to
terabytes for the BigTable size here
this works really great for write once
read many use cases so if you have a lot
of data that gets written once or
written infrequently let's say I can
discover weekly if you write that once a
week and we want to read it multiple
times when users come back to it and
keep listening to it the same playlist
BigTable works really really great for
this and there's some other great
features a big table that allow this to
be even more maintenance free and
effortless but I'll talk about that in a
second another use case that we have our
cloud BigTable is to use it as a caching
layer so rather than just using the
serve data in real time which it still
is in this graph here sometimes we'll
need BigTable to cache data in a kind of
distributed way so that systems that are
stateless can still use this distributed
cache to avoid having negative side
effects on other systems so a good
example here is if we use cloud dataflow
in
rather than in batch mode cloud dataflow
can be used to process streams of data
so as more data comes in you can operate
the same transforms and the same
operations on new data and in this case
sometimes we have cloud dataflow streams
that need to reach out to other services
they might need to talk to back-end
services or api's or things like that
and if we did so without any sort of
caching this could very quickly
overwhelm these back-end services we
could have a stream of data coming in
and if we imagine every single element
in that stream results in the request to
a back-end service it's very easy to
overload that and make that fall over
cloud BigTable works really really well
here because we can make a request to
BigTable as a cache first and we run the
risk of otherwise breaking these back in
services so this is this distributed
cache at the stateful layer around this
stateless cloud dataflow service again
in this application the cache sizes
range from gigabytes two terabytes but
it really depends on the exact
application being used here all right so
our third use case for cloud BigTable
here this is a common one the my team
works on this is cloud BigTable as a
platform datastore and this takes a
little bit more explanation here so we
often train multiple different types of
machine learning models especially for
music recommendation purposes and these
models have slightly different
properties or the different versions of
the same kind of thing when we train
these models we want to produce some
sort of intermediate data that we can
use for recommendation an example of
this is we might embed some data into a
certain space producing vectors in that
space and when we take all this this
resulting data it doesn't make sense on
its own we couldn't serve this data
directly to clients or to users and say
here these are your recommendations
these are not recommendations these are
really intermediate pieces of data that
can be used to produce recommendations
but they themselves are not the
recommendations so we use BigTable four
here is as a platform data store to
store all of this intermediate data for
all of these different models that we
might be testing or ever using for
different use cases BigTable works
really really great here because we can
scale this as big as we need to we can
add more models for experimentation we
can have bigger models smaller models
all this kind of stuff just gets shoved
into BigTable and then we wrap this big
table in a companion back-end service so
this green box right here that companion
back-end service can manage things like
access control business logic and
caching so that any consumers that want
to use this recommendations data
call the backend service and have one
unified API for accessing this big table
that stores all the underlying machine
learning data so this has been a very
very successful project of ours to use
BigTable in this manner and this this
does drive a lot of our recommendation
systems including some of the stuff that
I showed you earlier like the homepage
on Spotify I mentioned a couple times
that we we do dump date it into data
flow or sorry into BigTable from cloud
data flow and that can be as easy as
these ten lines of code here so we have
a framework in-house and also open
source called geo it's from the latin to
learn apparently and co allows you to
write very small amounts of code in
scala in what looks like almost like a
dsl to read data from certain places map
it filter it transform it and
essentially build up an apache
beam-style
processing graph in scala with these ten
lines of code here we can read data from
a Google Cloud storage bucket here map
that on to what we want to look like in
BigTable and then with one single line
at the bottom save as a big table there
we can dump all that data into the big
table all at once so CHEO is really
really useful for bridging these two
worlds and doing complex needed
processing and integrates super nicely
with with BigTable I'll talk a little
bit more about Co later on as well but
definitely take a look at this on github
if you're interested I also mentioned
the BigTable has some very nice
properties that make it good as a cache
one of those properties is using its
built in garbage collection policy or
it's built an expiration feature now
BigTable allows you to set a maximum age
for your data based on the column family
and the table that it lives in this is
directly from Google's developer
documentation but this max age parameter
says that maybe after seven days or
thirty days you want the data that
you've written to automatically expire
from the cluster and this means that you
don't need to do any sort of management
of your cluster you don't need to have
another process read over the data and
automatically delete it for you this
happens in the background
opportunistically and you don't need to
waste any CPU on it or any of your your
mind really like this just happens
automatically this is a super super
useful and you can think of many use
cases where if you have a write once
read many application this can just make
your your maintenance headache go away
so we definitely recommend this another
thing about using BigTable for these use
cases is that although it does have a
very expressive schema design it's
possible for you to
use all of its column families and other
features like that to express your data
in in its language we found that it can
be useful to treat BigTable as a very
very simple map so essentially a
distributed key-value store where you
have one key and you have one value so
in this example we've kind of ignored
the column qualifier of the column
family as well we just have them as
single characters here because honestly
all we really need is one big
distributed key-value store and if we
have these column qualifiers and column
families as single characters that even
makes our processing faster we have to
send those calling qualifiers on every
single request so keeping those as small
as possible is of interest to us and we
found that if we encode our values as
protobuf or JSON as long as we don't
need to do any filtering on those values
or ask to be able to process them before
it fetches them for us this can be
extremely efficient and also lends
itself well to doing caching in the
application layer and other similar
things so BigTable while it does have a
lot of features can be used in this
extremely simplistic way to get really
really great performance out of it all
right
so let's talk a little bit about scaling
challenges as I mentioned before we have
petabytes of data stored across hundreds
of BigTable clusters and so we've run
into a number of different challenges
trying to scale BigTable to meet our our
application load so the first problem
we've run into is how to scale the
cluster during ingestion if as I
mentioned before we're trying to ingest
huge amounts of data via cloud dataflow
all at once into a BigTable cluster
sometimes we'll easily overwhelm the
cluster with that that write volume this
is a graph of actually I don't know
which cluster this was you can see that
at different times when we're ingesting
data will have huge spikes in CPU
utilization and this is not conducive to
having a good user experience right you
want to make sure that when you ingest
it into your system you're not
overloading it such that the read
requests essentially get drowned out and
have a forward latency so what we found
is a good technique is that will scale
the BigTable cluster up just before
doing ingestion so we'll start our
dataflow pipeline and the first thing
they'll do is it will change the number
of nodes in the cluster that it wants to
write into so you can do this easily via
the the BigTable API and you'll
temporarily scale this up by a factor of
maybe 2 or 3 or some factor that we
compare to determine make sense for this
use case once we scale it up we'll then
adjust all the data at the maximum
feed that data flow will allow us to do
and even at that speed we won't impact
the read request so we'll have still
good user experience during that entire
process and then once that's done we'll
wait a little while as well for the data
to settle down and find its right home
then once that's done we can drop the
size back down again so we're not over
provisioned and spending extra money on
capacity that we don't need at all times
so in a timeline that's this is what
this looks like we add nodes to the
cluster well wait for the cluster size
to increase waits for some additional
time for caches to warm and things like
that
well ingest data all at the maximum
speed we possibly can and then wait for
that data to settle and once that's done
we'll remove those extra nodes of the
cluster to keep our costs low and this
solution tends to work fairly well
however there is a new feature from
cloud big tables team that might make
this no longer necessary and that is the
BigTable replication feature that
they've recently launched now it's
possible to have multiple clusters
replicate to each other or rather
replicate from one cluster to another
cluster and what we found is that if we
have a right cluster and a read cluster
and set up replication in between them
this can help us solve this problem in a
slightly different way so in this
diagram here at the very top we have
cloud dataflow writing a huge amount of
data in that's that very thick arrow and
the right cbt cluster here is taking all
those writes in it might be a cluster
that's larger or may be for vision
differently so that it can accept all
this capacity and then big tables a
synchronous replication will take that
data from the right cluster and write it
into the read cluster automatically this
writing happens in the background it's
not it's not something you need to kind
of manage yourself you just turn it on
and then it runs when it can this also
means that this usage is eventually
consistent so if you need instant
consistency for your data this is not
something that you can really use for
that use case but once the data has all
been adjusted into the right cluster at
some time afterwards the idea will have
propagated through the read cluster
without affecting the read clusters read
latency or anything like that and that's
great that means that we can get this
high performance and the back-end
service never really knows that we did
in ingestion and all we had to do was
set up replication between two different
clusters if you in mind though that if
you use a solution like this you'll have
to keep two clusters up and doing all
that management does take a little bit
of extra cost in a bit of extra time so
really pick one of these two
Solutions depending on your use case
another problem we've had when trying to
scale BigTable involves optimizing our
key spaces so this graph on the screen
here is a screenshot from Google
stackdriver tool which allows you to
visualize the activity in your BigTable
cluster per row so the axes here a
little bit confusing time is across the
bottom so from left to right you have
time going forward the row key in your
database is from top to bottom so you
essentially have rows that start with a
at the top and rows that start with Zed
at the bottom let's say and then the
color of each cell here is the activity
for that row at that time so in this
graph here the brightness on the
left-hand side of the graph is an
ingestion taking place and then over
time as the ingestion finishes the color
is kind of become more muted to show
that there's less traffic over time but
nonetheless the traffic is kind of
evenly distributed no one row in this
database has more reads or writes than
any other rows in this database for
instance so this is a very important
property if some of these rows received
a lot more traffic than other rows this
database would not be easily scalable
and I'll talk about why in a second
let's say we have a key visualizer that
looks like this very similar to the last
one but now there's a bright line across
the middle of the graph that bright line
is telling us that one row key has more
reads and writes than the rest of the
cluster and that's a sign that this one
this one key because it's so hot it's
it's kind of limiting the scalability of
our cluster and causing us to kind of
waste money on our cluster if we try to
scale it up and let me show why that is
so we're gonna do an exercise together
you don't have to do anything just sit
there but imagine this is our row key
space this is all of the keys in our
BigTable cluster we have the entire
alphabet and we want this big table
cluster to have two different nodes in
it so a two node cluster with 26 keys
the first 13 go to node 1 and the second
13 go to node 2 this is not something we
can configure this is how BigTable
segments your key space no matter what
so essentially the keys are sorted
alphabetically or technically
lexicographically and this means that if
you add more nodes
it'll just chop up the key space in in
the same exact way and each node will
get a proportional
at the key space now there's a big
asterisk there and that certain
situations can cause big table to kind
of rebalance the cluster a little bit
more but you always have this
alphabetical set up happening here
so in this cluster node 1 and node 2
both have 50% of the traffic to the
cluster so the key space is perfectly
even no key is receiving more traffic
than any other key and it's easy to
scale this if we add more nodes weari
shard and everything gets really quick
and even better our 99th percentile read
time right now is only 10 milliseconds
so if this is a metric that's important
it's certainly important to us you want
to make sure that in the 99th percentile
are read times are so good so 10
milliseconds pretty good for this
cluster that's kind of our target now
let's say that something goes wrong we
get a traffic spike to a hot key that
starts with J and J is currently on node
1 there so with a huge amount of new
traffic coming into this one key what's
gonna happen to the cluster and more
importantly what's going to happen to
our read time if we do the math it turns
out that node 1 now gets 90% of the
traffic to the cluster and node 2 only
gets 10% keep in mind that node 2 is
still serving the same number of
requests it was before it's just that
there's so much more traffic going to
node J that it's kind of skewing the
balance between these two nodes and if
we look at the number at the top here
the 99th percentile read time is now
shot up to 60 milliseconds that's pretty
bad
if we started at 10 milliseconds now
we're at 60 that's probably gonna trip
some alarm and wake someone up at 3 in
the morning so if I'm that engineer who
woke up at 3 in the morning he's trying
to solve this problem what do I do well
big table allows me to have one
parameter to configure and that is the
number of nodes in the cluster so let's
say I'm kind of groggy you don't know
what's going on I try to fix the problem
by turning up the number of nodes in the
cluster and that gives me this a cluster
that has four nodes in it and each of
these four nodes now has a quarter of
the row space node one contains a
through G no 2 is G through M node three
is n through T and so on but the key
that starts with J there is still
receiving a lot more traffic than all
the other keys in the cluster so we do
the math again here we see that we now
have a very unbalanced cluster nodes 1 3
& 4 are each serving 5 percent of the
traffic which is great they have a lot
of capacity and they're going to be very
fast however in the worst case our
99th percentile case no.2 is serving 85%
of our traffic and that 85% is much
worse than we expected it to be we
wanted to double the number of nodes and
thus cut the latency in half but in
effect we've really only cut the latency
down by 3 milliseconds what gives why is
it that we can double the number of
nodes and thus our cost and not get a
performance game well we did the math
and pull out your phones you might want
to take a screenshot of this this is the
relationship between the latency of your
cluster and the the ratio of the traffic
to your hottest key to the traffic to
the medium key to the customer knowledge
this is this is what we go off of and
this is how we understand how to scale
BigTable so if the traffic to your
hottest key is very very high and the
traffic to your median key is very very
low and the ratio between them is is
very significantly more than 1 then this
is going to limit scalability by a large
factor if the traffic of the hottest key
and the medium key are the same that
ratio ends up being just 1 and then the
traffic your cluster is divided by all
the nodes in the cluster and you're
golden you can scale as much as you want
to just by increasing that number of
nodes it might be more useful to see
this as a graph though because certainly
this doesn't make any sense to me here's
this plotted as a graph so let me
explain what this means across the very
bottom of the graph here we have the
number of nodes in your big typical
cluster at the very left hand side of
the graph that's a big table cluster
that has one node in it and at the very
right hand side that's a big table
cluster that has a hundred nodes in it
so you can turn that dial from 1 to 100
or beyond very very easily the 4
different lines in this graph represent
4 different distributions of data in the
cluster so at the very top we have a red
line that red line is what happens if
you have one key receiving 100 percent
of the entire traffic to the cluster if
you add more nodes to the cluster that
will not fix your your latency will not
add throughput because essentially that
one key is still only being served by
one node the additional nodes that you
add don't do anything because they don't
only dt8 it that's actually being used
for anything so that's the worst case
scenario this is why you don't want to
use BigTable for just one piece of data
essentially the best-case scenario is
the opposite here it's the green line at
the very bottom that's what happens if
you have flat traffic distribution no no
T is more more loaded than any other key
in the cluster and that Green Line is
great that means
that if you have one node your latency
might be 100 milliseconds if you have
two nodes your latency might be 50
milliseconds for nodes 25 milliseconds
and so on your latency is essentially
the traffic to your cluster divided by
the number of nodes that's why we get
this nice this nice line here because at
100 nodes in theory each node is only
processing 1% of the traffic so you get
a really really great scalability curve
here we have two curves in the middle
that kind of show why you care about
this if you have different distributions
of data if one key receives a hundred
times the median traffic that's the
orange line second to the top there you
can add more nodes to the cluster and it
will get better the scalability will
improve and your P ninety-nines will
improve but not by that much
that's because one node is still
significantly bottlenecking the rest of
your cluster the yellow line second from
the bottom there that's another example
that's what happens if one key receives
ten times the median traffic which
doesn't seem like too much but adding
more nodes will still not increase your
performance in the worst case so this is
definitely something that we've used to
try and re our katar systems that
Spotify to make sure that everyone gets
a good experience every single time all
right
so if having your key space designed in
a certain way is super important how do
you design your schemas what are some
good tips and tricks to make sure you
don't run into this problem well
choosing an evenly distributed key space
is probably the number one thing you
need to care about in your schema design
for BigTable and there are three
strategies that run into here they're
all there in order of worse to best so
strategy number one is not something you
should do
strategy number three is something that
I would recommend doing so I'll go
through them in order and talked about
why you shouldn't do them or should do
them so the first strategy for
disturbing your keys across the entire
key space is to hash all the keys so you
could take the keys that you would
regularly put in the database let's say
they may be their usernames or something
like that and just hash them pick a non
cryptographic hash function doesn't need
to be secure it just needs to be fast
because the only purpose of this is to
distribute this data across the cluster
this works great and technically you can
do this and you'll get good performance
however this is not good for a whole
bunch of other reasons
if you hash this data randomly or hash
it with a hash function you can't use
CBT anymore you can't use your debugging
tools you can't read the key space on
your screen you
make sense to you it's essentially
obfuscated and that's not good for
debugging or for developing applications
you also can't do range scans on this
data so if your if your keys have common
prefixes it's very easy in BigTable to
do range scans and say start at this key
and go until you hit this key well if
your keys are hashed there they're
effectively randomly distributed which
is great for performance but not good
for any sort of data locality or sort of
like understanding where where data is
similar to other data so a good second
approach is to reverse all the keys in
your key space so we tried this for a
little while assuming you have some sort
of numeric ordering meaning that the the
digit at the very right of your data or
at the least significant digit changes
more often than the most significant
digit so an example of this is maybe
time stamps if you had time stamps in
BigTable you could reverse the keys and
then the digit that changes most
frequently every second would
essentially scatter your data across all
the different nodes in the cluster this
again technically works you could
reverse all the keys before inserting
the data and then reverse all the keys
when you read again this is also more
human readable and we're debuggable
because you can see that data they're
kind of read it backwards and put it
through a script or something like that
and and now it's possible to do that but
this is still not great there's still a
better solution available and that's
solution number three here which is to
promote the most random field from your
data to the row key so try to find
something in your data that can be used
to impart some randomness into your Oh
key and move that from the value that
you're storing into the row itself so if
you have some sort of a random
identifier let's say maybe it's an item
ID or a UUID or something like that
and if that's consistent in your data
and it's not it's it's random but it's
deterministic try to put that into your
okey that's distributing that data
randomly across your cluster but still
giving you some business logic you can
do on top of that this preserves
readability uses very little CPU
overhead AIDS debugging and allows you
to do range scans if those keys are
consistent so I keep talking about these
range scans and I haven't really defined
exactly what they are
so in BigTable because all the data is
ordered alphabetically or
lexicographically you can scan from one
key to another very very simply you can
tell a big table to start a scan at a
certain place and end ask and another
place and even do a prefix scan on that
because that's essentially the same
thing if you have a random distribution
of your data across the cluster
and your key space you can still do
these ro range scans provided that you
know what the first section of your data
looks like and if you exploit this even
more you can have tiered keys so tier
keys are where the first section of your
key is kind of a superset of all the
later sections of the key and let me let
me talk a little bit of what that means
so here's a very contrived example don't
do this it's just for explanation
purposes here but let's say that you're
keying your data in BigTable by keys
that look like this they start with the
country that your data is in the region
the city and then the district and all
of these form the same key so your keys
might look something like this where
you'd have the country at the first part
here so Canada followed by the region or
state or province or whatever you have
there then the city and then a district
this means that you can do range scans
on this data very very effectively if
you wanted to find all of the cities in
California let's say you could aspect
able to range scan from the start of USA
: California to the end of USA Cola
California and that would give you all
those rows in one query this is great
however this still doesn't randomly
distribute the data across your entire
database so you have a bit of
performance problems here and one
strategy around that is to remove the
first part of the key if you know that
it has low cardinality so in this case
there are only 190 odd countries in the
world and because of that all of the USA
data would be at the very bottom of your
cluster at the those nodes there and all
the data for certain countries would be
kind of right next to each other so to
get around that you can take this
mapping of let's say country to region
or some other very very low cardinality
mapping and put that into your
application and then in BigTable you
could store just the second layer of
your key forward there are many more
regions in the world many more states
and provinces than there are countries
and now doing this allows you to
randomly distribute this data or not
randomly but put that across the cluster
in a way that helps you scale without
without kind of hot spotting on certain
areas of the cluster let's talk about
one more example here this is the key
design for doing range scans over data
that involves IDs so this is a real
example from Spotify as data obviously a
AAA one and BB two are not real users
this is all kind of made-up but but this
is a real task that we have to solve and
this is what what do we do if we want to
know what tracks a user has listened
so if I'm use either AAA one and I've
listened to track one at timestamp one
two three we can store that in BigTable
with a schema that looks like this start
with a 1 and the second part of the key
is track 1 and then the timestamp
encodes exactly when I listen to that
and then if I want to do a range scan
and find out exactly when this user has
listened to all these tracks
well I asked BigTable to range can hey
one give me all the rows that start with
this value and it gives me back hundreds
maybe thousands maybe tens of thousands
of rows and each row contains both that
user ID and a track they've listened to
and the time they listen to that track
now because this is a tiered key
structure I can go even further I can
say tell me not just when user a a one's
listen to this track but specifically
track two so if I do a row range scan
from a a one including track two I'll
get all the different plays that user
has had of that track and that gives me
all those rows that are kind of
continuous next to each other in that
BigTable cluster so this is a super
useful technique to try and put your
data in a format that will be both
scalable and performance across BigTable
but also in a way that you can still get
this kind of performance you would
expect out of a relational database with
multiple indices okay I'm just running
along here this took less time than I
expected but let's talk a little bit of
an open source so I mentioned earlier we
have some tools that are very very
useful you can use this in your own
pipelines and get your data processing
done much quicker with some of these
tools so we love open source we have a
lot of open source projects on github if
you check out github slash Spotify
you'll find these projects and many many
more the first route you want to talk
about is a project called shield so like
I mentioned before Co comes from the
Latin to learn it is a Scala based
framework for Apache beam and Google
Cloud dataflow and it's inspired by
Apache spark in scalding it's fairly
popular in the open-source community now
it's got a couple thousand stars on
github if that's a measure of popularity
and we use this very very heavily
internally to try and do all of our data
processing so like the example I showed
you before this allows us to let's say
grab data from GCS and dump that into
BigTable with maybe only ten lines of
code we could also do complicated data
pipelines you can map filter do all the
operations you'd expect from a
functional programming language but
large sets of data on cloud data flow in
the cloud so she is super super useful
check that out on github there are lots
of tutorials and other documentation
available and we'd love to start using
that simple BigTable is the second thing
on the slide here this is a simpler more
asynchronous BigTable client for Java
and Scala now the official Big Dipper
client works just fine it's just a
little bit verbose so what we did was we
wrote a simpler client it's based on the
Java build a pattern and it allows you
to do asynchronous operations against
BigTable with a very small amount of
code this also powers a lot of our
production experiences when I mentioned
earlier that discover weekly in the home
page and stuff like that is all served
at a big table it's going through this
library so this is production-ready code
try to use that and you'll see your
BigTable interactions become much tercer
in your code and easier to work with and
finally I want to talk a little bit
about a project called annoy and annoy
is a library for approximate nearest
neighbors calculations what that means
is if you're doing machine learning and
you have representations of data and no
allows you to select similar data in
spaces I'm not doing a machine learning
talk here so I'm not going to get too
much into it but it's approximate
nearest neighbors and the oyi think
stands for oh yeah
but annoy again on github very popular
lots of stars very performant library
not the most performant library in the
world that has great support bindings
for most major languages and it's very
widely used in the community so try to
use the NOI if you have machine learning
tasks that could use nearest neighbor
lookups and with that I've breezed
through this talk again my name is Peter
sohbat senior engineer on the
recommendations team at Spotify in New
York tweet at me at piezo bot or at
Spotify edge and please do give feedback
in the app there in the google cloud
next to app this feedback goes back to
the group of proud team to figure out
which sessions to have next time thank
you so much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]